let's talk about some of the stuff that
you've been able to do
i mean we talk about chicago times
square you know
a niagara falls i know started up with
niagara falls in june 15 of 2012 then
it's chicago then it's time square
dennis volcano
which one was the first official big one
you did in your eyes
where you say this is when people said
this guy's gonna be
doing stuff like his grandpa did and
doing big stuff in his life which one
was it for you
i would tell you it was in 2000 uh let's
see it was 2008
and i had an opportunity to uh break a
world record live on the today show
and it's one that's not not very very
much talked about but i
rode a bicycle on a wire 135 feet above
the streets of newark
new jersey for a distance of about 200
feet which set two world records in fact
the record prior to that was about 40
feet so i tripled that record
uh both ways and actually almost five
times as far as length goes so
um that was the one that sort of
launched my career in a sense however i
would tell you
that after that walk i got off on the
other side and
and matt lauer said what are you going
to do next nick and i said i want to be
the first person to walk across the
grand canyon on a tightrope
and within six weeks i signed a contract
with nbc
to be the first person to walk across
the grand canyon and
you look at my timeline it doesn't match
up and the reason being was
about six months into that process all
the engineering was done the site was
was prepped uh the cable was purchased
we were ready to go
nbc fired the head of specials that
contracted me to do that
and when that happened my special went
out the door with him so we got a call
and said hey
sorry nick uh this ain't happening where
they told my managers we're we're gonna
take this off of our slate
and i remember the wind being knocked
out of my sails because here i thought
that this is what our family needed in
order to
be able to actually support stop eating
the feathers and start eating chicken
full time
and uh so i thought this was the big
break and and again six months into that
literally three months from that special
happening live
it got pulled out from under me and i
remember just going back and thinking
and i often think to my great
grandfather like what would he do here i
just feel like giving up
i don't feel like carrying on and and i
always look to him for inspiration and
just like he got back on the wire after
that accident in 1962
the following day uh he continued on
against all odds and all these tragedies
i thought you know what my great
grandfather would keep pushing and i'm
not gonna give up
but i'm going to i'm going to kind of
change my direction a little bit and i
knew that niagara falls
a there was a lot more uh there's a lot
more business in that area that would be
able to help fund this because it was
going to cost
it ended up costing over a million
dollars to rig that wire to do this walk
and through that process i realized i
was gonna have to change two laws one in
the united states over 100 years old and
one in canada
in order to get permission and i i felt
like if i can get the government behind
this and through that process
we can get a bunch of momentum behind us
then a
network will sign on and we can get a
bunch of sponsors and endorsements
that'll actually cover the cost
and in fact that's what happened after a
year of trying to get permission and
going through senators
governor cuomo signed legislation giving
me an exemption to that 100 year old law
to walk across niagara falls
then i still had to go to canada and
that was another process that was a
nightmare but eventually got through
that
and through that process i got a tweet
from from good morning america
and abc and she said would you be
willing to come on our show and i said
of course so i flew to new york city was
on the show and she said well you stay
after your interview
uh the president of of news division
here at abc would like to speak with you
and we sat down and they ended up
agreeing to cover the costs but what
people don't realize was that in the end
that walk over niagara falls cost me
thirty thousand over thirty thousand
dollars thirty to forty thousand dollars
out of my own pocket when i didn't have
it in order to do that walk but i knew
it was an investment that would take me
into my future in fact
we had a gofundme that helped cover some
of those costs prior to back when that
was a brand new thing
prior to me taking that walk because the
network didn't cover all the costs
so so what was the 30 to 40 000 cost for
you
uh it was just an addition to the
rigging there was extra stuff that was
mandated on me in fact
about two weeks before that walk i was
walking over the inner harbor in
baltimore
another parallel of my great grandfather
he walked over that inner harbor
back in the 60s and i went back to
recreate it but again i always try to
honor him and do something unique so i
decided i was going to walk from the
land
to a crane that was on a barge so as i
was walking that wire was moving quite a
bit
because of course in that harbor there's
there's waves smaller waves but enough
movement on a barge
that that that crane was moving about
three quarters the way up there was
about
30 000 people in attendance live and
good morning america was covering it
live
and i made my way up three quarters away
and one of my best friends was in a
basket at the top ready to take my
balancing pole
and i looked at him and i said hey chris
do you want to see 30 000 people scream
and he goes yeah because he knew exactly
what i was gonna do somebody i grew up
with
and i acted like i was gonna fall and i
slipped i did a fake slip on the wire
and thirty thousand and one people
screamed because it wasn't just the
thirty thousand in attendance
but the president of abc was watching
and what happened was before i got on
the wire
my manager had a a text from the
president of
abc news in all caps saying what was
that
and that turned into a tailspin of them
saying we're not going to air this
so here i am again this is two weeks
from walking across niagara falls
abc says we're pulling the plug on this
and they're funding it
uh a long story short what it came down
to was we negotiated with him and they
said we'll allow him to do it but if he
does he has to wear a tether
so my biggest fear walking over niagara
falls was that tether because i'd never
worn one in my entire career
until until that day live on abc and my
concern was
is this going to trip me up my great
grandfather always taught that
safeties are a false sense of security
and the reason he said that was he had
an older brother that bounced
fell into a net bounced out and was
killed so even though you have a safety
device it makes your mind think oh
everything's fine i'll be okay i got a
safety device but the reality is it
isn't and if you can become if you
become complacent
because you have a net that's when you
you can be in grave danger